SKRRRRA
SKRRRRRRRRRRRR
*inhales*
(Gibberish)
ATTAR DU
FÖRLORAR DU
MANEN
It feels good to make another one of these.
Funny videos go hahahaa.
Let's Go
Remember the rules. They are very simple.
You laugh, you lose.
You laugh, you click away this video right now
and watch all my other videos,
until you're back on this one
and then you start over.
Those are the rules
Nobody:               DreamWorks Animation:
Kowalski: I've done it!
*Clap* *Clap*
The Trans-dimensional Toothbrush!
King Julian: Ok buddy, but um, you got no teeth.
Kowalski: Right, but who can resist this!
Pewdiepie: Oh no, I know what this is.
*Deepthroat noises*
Hahahahaa.
*inhale*
DreamWorks Animations 10/10
This is not meme review.
*clap* Next clip. *clap*
Alright everyone who laughed,
I see you guys in 5,000 videos.
Everyone who didn't,
let's keep going.
That's hilarious.
James Charles
*snicker* hahahaha
*inhale*
And he's got the Pewdiepie pattern.
*clap* A plus *clap* *clap*
A plus *clap* Anthony.
I realize this is a dig at James Charles.
Hi sisters.
Haha
*laughing* What's her @?
*inhale*
Sometimes the comments are funny. Hey, that's great
*clap* Moving *clap* on.
Are you still with the challenge?
Let's fricking go.
Take your slurp of GFuel.
10% off Pewdiepie code.
wgauuah
And let's go.
Mario Kart 64 Voices Autotuned
(auto-tuned mario:NIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIINTENDOOOOOO WOOOOOOOOHOOOOOOOOO)
Hey that sounds pretty good!
Mario Kart
(auto-tuned luigi:YAHOOOOOO)
Ayee heh
*laughs*
That's pretty cool, I guess I don't know.
It's not really that funny
*clap* Next *clap* clip
All my shows is blurred into one.
It's all just:
Haha meme! haha someone else!
haha
Let's go!
*loud screech*
*kisses fingers*
Top-notch.
Finest meme i have ever seen in my life.
Jesus Christ
What i-
*clap* Next clip *clap*
Oh my god.
Come on little turtle.
You can d-
Oh it's going faster.
OH MY GOD! *chuckles*
That's not real. Is it real?
*laughs*
*inhales*
That was amazing!
Either way it's funny
*clap* Next clip *swipes hand*
ha ha ha ha ha
That's great. I don't think I'd see your spicy paste again
I'm not even trying at this point,
and you know why?
Because GFuel baby.
Glug glug glug glug gluug
Mmm. I'm drinking peach flavor.
Peach tea
*shakes bottle*
MMMMM
mmmmm
*puts bottle on desk*
Next skrattar
Oh my god
Oh ho my
Man in video: Oh the humanity!
See I always have to check myself.
What am I laughing at here?
Is that a horrific event that a lot of people got injured?
Not funny.
Let that just be clear media.
If people got injured,
I'm not laughing.
Hey look, it's another one of these quizzes.
Who do you look like quiz.
Thank you, okay
Uh-huh
You got Kanye West.
What he doesn't look anything like Kanye West.
Oh by the way,
6'8"
You're 6'8"?
Pathetic!
Haha, 5' 8'' to 5' 10''? *scoffs*
You're so short you might as well get a ladder to walk around
That's how short you are, 5' 10'', and I- wait am I 5' 11''?
5' 11''. See that's 1300 yeah. That's me, 5' 11'.
Let's keep moving. Next- next skrattar
Thank you. Thank you
Video: Look!
Ninja: I've been broken up with- I've broken up with girls, you know, some guys... wait
Video: I knew it!
Hahahaha
I. Frickin'. Knew it.
Ninja is Irish. Confirmed, everyone.
I knew as soon as he got that Jacksepticeye haircut
Unbelievable. That little gay streamer is Irish. Incredible
This is annoying me, I don't like it
*laughs*
He's like, "take it, take it please, I would-" *laughs*
Ahh that's great
When you get so- trolled so hard, you just want to die I get that feeling
These are some great skrattar so far
I must really say having great skrattar, if you made it this far
Incredible job. You've done it
But we're about to step up to the next three-er. This time it's three-er
Let's go.
Alex: You can just point us towards the administrative offices, or just...
Spider: Oh n***** you gay
*loud scream*
*claps* hahaha
"N-word you gay"? That's funny
The word is everywhere, what am I supposed to do? Pretend that it doesn't exist?
What am I supposed to do? I don't understand. What- what are the rules
If everyone stopped using it, it would be a lot easier. That's all I'm saying. Thank you
"Everybody gangsta until the Fortnite storm starts closing in"
First ever black hole image, please. What do we got?
Please don't be racist. It's all I ask
No racism
It's Sans. *laughs* I never been more happy to see Sans
Felix in video: A lot of people don't know this
Hey it's me! Oh look at that quality!
Felix in video: but if you knock on a really big bamboo
I told guys I had better quality in Japan
Felix in video: "special sound will come out"
*knocks twice*
Felix in video: Meme. Review.
Cuz I knocked twice, get it? *claps twice*
"When your WiFi stops working and you're forced to come out of your room"
Felix in video: Helloooo everybody!
It's a Pewdiepie joke, extra funny
If you're still in after that meme, then boooooy
You've got some strength to you. How about this one
Video: ¿Puppy?
Video: ¿Quieres? ("do you want" in Spanish)
Oh my God...
Why is this a meme?
NO! It means nothing
Sí, quiero, por favor ("yes, I want it, please" in Spanish)
Grazie mille ("thank you very much" in Italian)
What do you want me to say?
"When your mom comes in with the belt"
*terrified screech*
What are his life I don't understand
Oh no, no *laughs*
Goddamnit!
Video: here's *click click* the motherf**king *click click* tea
That's a great *claps* that's a great meme
Come on, THAT WAS A SKRATTAR!
That wasn't a laugh that was a question mark, hahaha
Next. Skrattar.
*smack*
*man screams*
Okay, don't know the context, that's why it's funny, hahahahahaha
That relatable moment when the priest smacks your belly so hard that you can't breathe
Video: Don't just talk about it
Video: Check out Sakura-Con, April 10 through 12
Video: Check sakuracon.org for-
I mean I've shown this a million times, but it's so God damn good
Video: Girugamesh!
GIRUGAMESH!
Video: I love anime!
Video: And manga!
This is why no one admits that they like anime
Video: And gaming!
AND GAMING!
Video *drowned out by Felix*: And DDR!
Video: Smile.dk!
Shut up! Shut up! No one cares about that
Video: Sakura-Con ikimasu ("let's go to Sakura-Con")
Sakura-Con does not- "ikimasu" does not mean "get your butts". It means "let's go to sakura-con".
I know because I. Studied. Nihongo ("Japanese")
Wakarimasu ("understand")
Nihongo ("Japanese")
I think I've played this game
It's like a type of game you played in school
Alright it looks like you are about to lose boy-
Oh, Oh! Oh! OH! OH! OH!
No! My God! Wow!
Wow!
That was amazing
That's all you need for a meme these days, what the hell
I have no idea what I watched, that's why it's funny!
Alright well, this has been Skrattar Du, Förlorar Du, Manen
Let's frickin' go bros, we did another episode
See you guys next frickin' week
And remember, check out the merch
Brand new merch link in the description.
It's only available right now, let's go bros.
Very epic merch
What? Tuber Simulator's becoming relevant
No, no, don't leave
No, please! Sponsor Eagle, please do something
Yes, yeah
This game is still relevant goddamnit!